please welcome eric kim
how does it feel when you get to drop
the mic and be like yeah i work for the
new york times
ah it feels i don't know that's my job
it's like my my day job that i love but
this all is just so new for me it's my
first book so this all feels very
surreal take us through the dish we are
making teach us teach us teach us yes
okay so this dish is very exciting near
and dear to my heart it is at the end of
this section called tv dinners and so yo
right now we have this kyobi going kaibi
is a short rib that's been cut a certain
way and it's a really convenient cut
because it cooks pretty quickly we're
just frying it with salt and pepper you
know i've tested this multiple ways but
the simplest is often the best so it's
quite easy we just need to flip it now i
think oh my god look at that here yeah
yours looks great oh god it smells so
good you got it so you know this is just
going and what you do is
start the potato salad while that's
going i love potatoes that would still
be good we should get jimmy out here
again because there's mayonnaise
i mean he really no good cheese it is
his kryptonite yeah so you know actually
what i'm to do is i'm just going to mash
this up this potato salad is like amped
up it's just so delicious and something
that you can bring to a picnic i like
having it a little warm and that's the
pleasure of making this at home because
this is actually we're going to see
it looks like the korean
uh restaurant kind it's we're gonna have
it like as a scoop and so we're just
adding some cucumbers you don't wanna
just i'm just getting rid of my excess
water you don't want the excess water so
these cucumbers have been drained with
like a little salt and it's kind of part
of my mom was like you need to um make
sure that there's no water in the
cucumbers and i thought that was genius
because it makes it makes the mashed
potatoes last longer in the fridge oh
yeah if there's less water
so
and then these vegetables does everyone
recognize these
a frozen medley
they came from a garden but it's just it
has to be this mix it has to be i love
the word
so this mayonnaise has vinegar and sugar
the sugar balances it don't be afraid
there's a little salt as well if you
want to season it later but you know you
add as much or as little as you want
honestly um and i probably do a little
salt because sauce good salt brings out
everything you know and when you mix it
up you'll see it's this really beautiful
it looks confetti i call it confetti
mashed potatoes
so this is called kanja sally tomja
potato and yeah we know salad um tell me
about the barbecue sauce okay so
yum that tastes good you can have a
taste if you if you want to like see how
how it's balanced you want to like add
salt
don't have pepper if you want it's all
over
what you like oh whoa it's good right
it's very simple
oh my god i was not expecting that
i love that there's a little bit of acid
there's a little acid yeah it's
important um but then you know the
mayonnaise it's also the sugar that you
might be reacting to wow balance is
everything else i'm all about balance
and that that reaction thank you i like
surprising people when they take a bite
they're like oh i wasn't expecting that
and the pea and the corn pops i love it
great it's really comforting i think
what's in the barbecue sauce so
this is the glaze that we're using to
you know lacquer these ribs that we've
cooked up and it's really just like
ketchup brown sugar worcestershire sauce
garlic it's like all these really
delicious ingredients i really think
that
these flavors what i loved about this
this book
and this recipe specifically is that
these
it tells a story of my cooking that i
remember growing up with but also my
mom's past and so this is sort of a love
letter to my mom and it's gonna make me
cry because i just i can't do this uh
press store without like talking about
my mom and crying but you know
she remembers eating this at restaurants
in in seoul when she was like a 19 year
old and i remember eating as a 19 year
old on my couch in georgia you know so
this book was an opportunity to like
talk to her and kind of interview her
and get to know her story and find those
resonances where we both kind of meet in
the middle and it's it's about bringing
the past into your present um and that's
kind of
the spiel that i have about the thesis
of this book which is write down your
family recipes but also also innovate a
little and have fun i think it speaks to
also what jimmy you know was here to
talk about is these books that really
celebrate your families if you're so
lucky to have them or the found families
that you create
and bringing children into knowing
that it's not to be taken for granted
and we have to keep those memories alive
so i think this is a perfect show to
honor your book and your family
[Music]